let's take some calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
let's start with a name and town where
are you calling from and what's on your
mind hey this is Michael in New York
how's it going Michael what's really
cool to be talking to you thank you okay
first of all I really appreciate your
commentary on everything that's going on
think I really enjoy your content that's
why I get your ear take your opinion on
the whole concept of anonymous sources I
would there seems to be a trigger that
the Trump campaign has set up for
themselves so anytime a news article
runs that cites an anonymous for unnamed
source their trigger is set off and they
immediately will a deny it and be take
it as an opportunity to attack that
reporter that organization and the
liberal media at large yeah so uh yeah I
just want to get your take on that we'll
live anonymously I think you're
absolutely not healthy to be skeptical
of any news report right we want to say
okay who is reporting this number one
you want to understand the possible
biases or conflicts of the media outlet
and then you also want to read the
sourcing and a lot of times this is
clicking back you might go to a website
that basically rewrites news and they're
sourcing something from a different
source and when you go to the original
source it might actually not say what
then is being paraphrased by the
rewriting website or whatever and
ultimately you get back to who are the
people that are the source here and of
course there's there's risks to running
good stories based on anonymous sources
there's a difference between an
unsourced story on infowars.com and the
New York Times saying we've talked to
three different sources who are
remaining in on who we are not
publicizing the names of because they
spoke on the condition of anonymity but
the New York Times knows who those
people are right so not an all anonymous
sources are the same a source that is
published by a known conspiracy
website and was anonymous to them is
very different than a more trustworthy
media outlet who says we are not
publishing the names of these sources in
order to keep them anonymous but we know
who they are so I think it's all on a
spectrum and of course the average
trumpets may not operate with this level
of nuance and precision and it's been a
super effective way Trump to just say
hey it's fake news you can't believe it
period yeah it seems that the Trump team
has gotten promised to to believe the
idea that anonymous source equals fake
stories or not only that not only that
Trump has gotten supporters some
supporters to believe that unless Trump
says it it just can't be believed and as
we've seen with the Russia constant
denials about the Russia stuff it's been
Trump who's been lying all along or a
clueless all along right if you want to
give them the sort of charitable benefit
of the doubt right super important thank
you so much for the call really
appreciated always great hearing from
from New York thank you and if I could
just say one more one more thing David
I'd really love every time you use the
word stunning I don't know why it looks
great so thanks again buddy all right
well stunning phone call thank you so
much really really appreciate it and we
will hopefully hear from him again